when you join the FBI you joined the
front line between order and chaos and
in today's world ya uzhe days to lose
perspective
identify these individuals and report
back to me you ever surf anything like
this
officer yeah that you obsessed anything
like this
welcome brother they called me bode
three crimes three continents
I think they're connected they're
attempting something called the ozaukee
a a series of eight ordeals that honor
the forces of nature so this is about in
latently exactly are you doing here in
time maybe I'm chasing the eight a
matter of fishes and boundaries
ultimately friends then come with us now
you've been on the cover for two weeks
you're using the money from the crimes
followers akis teachings we have to give
more no we take
there's a few million dollars up there
you're gonna steal it no
we're going to give it back
you've been on the ecology what just
went down was a crime
what they want to see they think they're
Crusaders were the worthy cause what
signing you are
I need to get to bode before the final
world you otherwise he's gone
hey stop we're all gonna town
the only question is how
Oh